[MUSIC PLAYING]
IVAN BOJER: Hello, everybody.
Welcome.
Thanks for coming.
This is your first
session, so I hope
you're all awakened by now.
We're going to talk
today about adding
advanced security to the Mix.
We're going to talk it out
today about some trends
that we're observing.
We're going to talk today
about why we believe
service mesh is important.
My name is Ivan
Bojer, and I'm here
with my esteemed colleague,
Vinay Venkataraghavan.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: Good try.
Some would say Vinay
Venkataraghavan.
IVAN BOJER: Some.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN:
Good morning.
IVAN BOJER: And
we're going to try
to explain to you what do we
do here at Palo Alto Networks
and why we think
this is important.
So before we start with
this, if you can just
give me a little bit with a
raise of hands, how many of you
is actually familiar with Istio?
Thank you.
How many of you are actually
familiar with something
other than Istio
in a service mesh?
And the last one is
that how many of you
actually have to have a
security team sanction
your apps before they can
be deployed to production?
We're going to today talk about
the container and microservice
trends.
We're going to tell you
about why some of it
is complex and
things that you have
to worry about that we observe.
We're going to talk about one
implementation of the service
mesh, Istio, which is
arguably probably the most
predominant out there.
We're going to talk about
some importance and advantages
of it, some pitfalls.
And we're going to then
explain to you guys
how we source out these with
our Palo Alto Networks Istio
solution.
And then at the end, we're
going to have a demo time
to show how it all
actually gels together.
So back in the days,
we're all familiar with
the monolithic applications.
You know, you had
usually three-tiered
model, mainly done
with a presentation
model and some
kind of middleware
and then persistence
model or storage.
There was very
understandable relations
between these three components.
Some are decoupled, but
yet they were very static
back in the days.
So really, although we
claim this is decoupling
in a three-tiered architecture,
our relations were very known
and understood.
Well, what comes next?
We came up with a service mesh.
We came up with microservices.
We came up with containers.
So now, containers are
just the current trend in--
helps you get to
the applications.
You know, but they helped
us actually kind of decouple
even more of our services, get
more performance out of them,
deal with the scalability,
workflow reliability,
and actually make things
a little bit easier--
or so we thought.
Because what they figured
out, as you deploy
your monolithic
applications into the sort
of microservices
architecture, you really
have to understand relations
between these services.
Some of them are very
related to each other.
Some are unrelated.
Some of them have to
scale really quickly.
Some of them, you know,
you don't care much about.
They're much more steady.
You need to understand
how closely they
live to each other, so they can
deal with the latest issues.
You have to figure out what
atomic service component
you got to worry about, or
how narrow you need to go
with each of your services?
So there's a lot
of questions you
got to ask yourself before
you deploy microservices.
So now, deploying microservices
itself is very easy.
You know, everybody that did
any development can probably
figure out very quickly how
to deploy the microservice
or how to develop one.
What wasn't easy figuring
out all the other relations
between them.
You know, let's
look at security.
In monolith architecture,
security is more or less known.
You're going to put your
security principles mainly
around perimeter,
your choke points.
What do you do in microservices?
I mean, there is really
no perimeter anymore.
It's kind of dissolving.
You're talking about north/south
in a monolithic architecture.
In microservices, you're going
to talk about north, south,
and east, west, and up and
down, and left and right.
So what do you do with it?
How do you figure this out?
What they figured out is
that actually building
those microservices is easy.
But to build them right
is actually really hard.
So now, imagine a world in
which actually microservices
are secure.
Imagine the world in
which agility for DevOps
is not impeded by
your security teams,
where it doesn't take two weeks
to approve your application,
that you can develop every
day and do updates every day
and release every day.
So this is the world we kind
of live every day in Palo Alto
Networks.
Coming from the security side
of things, especially enterprise
security--
enterprise security
doesn't move that quickly.
It's actually super slow.
It actually slows
down DevOps teams.
So how to combine these two
things together is a question,
and we're going to
show how to do that.
So now, as microservices
were maturing more and more,
there were some other
frameworks and components
which allowed us to
actually ease you out
of some of the job.
You know, starting
with Kubernetes,
number one
orchestrator out there,
it's very helpful in
deploying and orchestrating
your applications.
It helps you with
lifecycle management.
scaling up, scaling down.
It does all the
health checks for you.
Developers don't have
to worry about it.
However, it's like a little
bit on our network security
policies, because
it does have some.
However, those are usually at
the layer three, layer four,
supports basically
5 tuples, right?
Well, service meshes came
in, and service meshes
came in to actually help with
complexity of the networking
and topology and routing.
But also, they also came
in to kind of figure
out how to solve some
of the security issues.
It's still arguably probably
the number one implementation
of the service meshes.
Decided to kind of
figure out-- if we're
going to help you
with the routing,
we're going to help
you with security.
However, they just defined
the framework around security.
They let you
implement it yourself,
so figure out how you
want to deal with it.
You know, on the left screen,
left side of the screen,
this is adjust the visibility
into the Twitter microservices
architecture.
You can google it.
It's all over the place.
I mean, that does look easy.
How do you apply
security to that?
Some of them would like to
call this service mess, not
service mesh.
So it's a really
challenging problem.
So we at Palo Alto
Networks look at this
and try to figure out
how actually can we help.
How we can bring
enterprise-grade security
into the service meshes.
And there a couple
of ways we decided
we're going to go along this.
We figured out we need to bring
our high-level-grade security
in the service mesh.
So we got to be unified.
It should feel the same.
It should definitely
do the same thing
that we do everywhere else.
We figured out visibility
is very important,
because if you don't
see what's going
in your inter-pod traffic, then
how can you know what's really
going on in your network?
These are all blind spots.
You know, some of the other
services, like service meshes,
they can help you
with some of that.
But they only know
what they know.
So the set of the protocols
they support is very limited.
And the worst thing
is that really
don't knowing what
you don't know,
which means you don't have
visibility over things
that service meshes can't see.
So we can help with that.
And on top of that,
obviously there
is security for ingress,
egress, and inter-mesh itself.
So with all of that
said, I'm going
to give the microphone to
Vinay, so he can tell us
how do we actually do this.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: OK.
Great.
IVAN BOJER: Or do we?
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN:
Hopefully.
Great, thanks a lot, everyone.
And thanks, Ivan.
When we asked you guys how
many of you are adopting Istio,
it was great to see most
of you raised your hand.
So it looks like I'm going to
be not preaching but speaking
to the choir here.
But let's take a
pause and figure out
why we're doing this, right?
So we talked about
how microservices
are dominating predominant
production architectures today.
But why are we
doing that, right?
And when I tried to
answer that question,
I think primarily it's
driven by agility, right?
Because enterprises need to
deploy their applications.
They need to be
allowed to use those
to access those applications.
And they need to get it.
There needs to be a very
tight feedback loop, right?
Consequently, your developers
need to move very, very fast.
So let's talk about
then if we are proposing
that the industry
as a whole-- there
are service meshes
in architecture,
and Istio in particular--
how does Istio
help that perspective, right?
You know, your developers
now have the ability
to reason about your
applications as code.
Everything is as code.
Kubernetes and Istio
allow you to reason
about your
infrastructure as code.
Now you see how that
agility is facilitated.
However, and I'm going to
caveat my next statement
by saying I am a developer,
but I straddled both worlds.
Developers are not the
most security conscious.
I mean, they are working under
very, very tight timelines,
so they need to develop and
deploy code very, very fast.
So it is up to
the security teams
to enforce best
practices, make sure
that their deployments
are secure.
So from the first
perspectives-- so
the developers now
have the ability
to deploy all
their applications.
And they can use
Kubernetes and Istio
primitive to actually
connect their services,
ensure discoverability, and
ensure that the services are
actually usable.
Now, I've spoken to many,
many security practitioners
out there.
And I also saw some of
you raise their hands.
These applications can
never see the light of day
until it's sanctioned
by their security teams.
And I've already had a
chat with a few of you here
who can validate that, right?
So what does Istio
do to provide that?
So Istio actually allows
you to give abstract out,
fundamental services that
your development team,
that your applications
absolutely need.
So let's talk about
what they are, right?
Encryption.
You need encryption
between your services.
You need mutual TLS.
You need authentication
and a host
of variety of services
that are required
by each and every application.
So now you can see how
this fosters secure--
provides security, but
also fosters agility
by abstracting out
these services.
And your development teams
can now focus on their job
at hand, which is the line of
business application, right?
So Istio provides
these primitives
by giving you these
capabilities and allowing
you to enforce
these capabilities
with zero changes to your code.
And I think that's
a win-win situation.
So now let's talk about--
really briefly, before
we get into the really
meat of this presentation, but
how does Istio do this, right?
So Istio is
fundamentally comprised
of three major services.
One is Pilot.
The other one is Mixer.
And the other one, the last
one, but not least, is Citadel.
So we're going to focus on the
Mixer architecture here today,
but I want to quickly just
round out the value proposition
provided by Pilot.
This is what allows you
to connect your services,
allow you to do the
traffic management,
load balancing, service
discovery, et cetera, right?
And Citadel allows you to
distribute certificates,
to make sure that your
applications are authenticated,
and also use the
necessary encryption.
So having said that, let's get
into what the services provided
by Mixer are and
how we can leverage
that to provide a deep security
for all your applications
running on Kubernetes
with Istio.
So this slide talks about
the Mixer architecture.
I wanted to quickly go
over it and describe
the salient aspects of this.
To your right of the screen--
well, fundamentally, it all
hinges upon the Envoy proxy.
So typical deployments
in a pod, which
is the fundamental unit of work
in a Kubernetes environment,
is the fact that there's
always an Envoy proxy that
fronts your application.
So Envoy is the one
that actually has
a very rich set of attributes
that it uses to actually expose
an API, which is
called the XDS API,
to control planes such as Istio
that can leverage this data
and provide
value-added services.
So then let's dig deeper
into the Mixer architecture.
Essentially, Mixer
is a rules engine,
and it's comprised at a
very, very high level,
at the risk of
simplifying it too much,
by three different components.
So you have a set of rules that
defines exactly what actions
need to be taking place and
what actions Istio Mixer needs
to take place in order
to facilitate integration
with adapters that
are supported.
What an instance is
to say, hey, what
is this information that I need
to send when a rule is matched?
And then, it's also
comprised of these adapters.
So I also wanted to
showcase the fact that when
you deploy Mixer
and Istio today,
that you get a lot
of inbuilt adapters
that are built into the whole
Istio framework, which provide
lots of value-added services.
So it allows you to perform
some kind of RBAC, allows
you to integrate a lot of
telemetry into back ends,
such as Prometheus.
But I also want to highlight
that now we have built
a security adapter for Mixer.
And we are the first vendor
to build a security adapter
for Mixer.
I'm very happy to make
that announcement today.
So what we have done is
we're going to bring--
we're going to leverage
these capabilities provided
by Istio in general.
So Envoy actually
services two API calls.
One is a check API call, and
one is a report API call.
And I think you can see how we
actually progress with this.
The check API call is
used to enforce policy
across the service mesh.
And then the report
API call is used
to surface a lot of fine-grained
telemetry and information
about traffic patterns that
are traversing your network.
So having laid the groundwork
for this Mixer architecture,
let's get into how exactly
Palo Alto leverages
this kind of a
framework to provide
this kind of deep security
for containerized workloads.
So before we get
into that, I also
wanted to talk about a certain
pitfall blind spot, right?
So what you see here is a
subset of the Istio attribute
vocabulary.
So what that is is these
are the information that
is surfaced by the Envoy
proxies that can be leveraged
for different use cases, right?
But what I wanted
to highlight here
is the fact that we're all
coming from an enterprise
world, where we think IP
addresses are very, very
important.
We have applications,
static applications
that don't change much.
So we can leverage and
hook off of the IP address.
However, in a
microservices world,
things are changing
very, very rapidly.
You have a large
number of services.
So I just wanted to
point out the fact
that IPs don't mean much
in this kind of world.
It means a lot from a
networking perspective,
but not from a
security perspective.
So we're going to show you how.
This is what we talk
about up-leveling
the framework provided
by Istio to provide
fine-grained security, where
now we focus on transforming,
for example, Palo Alto
Network security policies
and map it into
namespaces, services,
application IDs, et cetera.
So the first
integration that we have
built out using Istio is
to leverage the report API
surfaced by Envoy and Istio
to show fine-grained telemetry
about all accesses that are
going on in your service mesh.
So we now map this back to
the attribute vocabulary,
so we can tell you which source
namespace that a request came
from, what was the
source service, what
was the HTTP verbs.
What was the action?
What were the parameters
for that connection,
such as, was encryption enabled?
Was a mutual TLS, et cetera?
So this is very, very
significant information.
And I'm actually
going to give you
a story that I actually even
real experience yesterday
about the benefits
of this capability.
And if you don't have
visibility into the traffic
patterns of your
environment, I think
it's a recipe for disaster.
So what we have done is we have
actually hooked our security
adapter, which is now called the
Next Generation Firewall Policy
engine to source information
from Envoy and Mixer
and actually integrate
all the data,
all the application logs and
metrics into the Palo Alto
Networks Cortex Data Lake.
We have built up this adapter
as a highly plug-in system,
so consequently, the
first initial integration
that we have also done is
with Google's Stackdriver.
So all of this
information is now
aggregated into a
single unified console.
And now you're able to reason
about all your application
patterns, what's going on.
And now, as you can see,
we can use this information
to troubleshoot
and also make sure
that your applications are
behaving as they should be.
So the data source for all
of this information is Envoy.
We harvest all of the data and
aggregate it into the Palo Alto
Networks Cortex Data Lake.
So here is a slide
that gives you
a sense of exactly-- we
have a lot of data going,
but gives you an idea as to
exactly what that data looks
like.
And this is a subset.
As you can imagine, we can
surface all the attributes
that Envoy exposes.
But to give you an idea,
so you have a timestamp.
You have a severity
level of the logging.
What was the source
service that initiated
that particular connection?
You have the
destination service.
You have source IP.
So you have a wealth
of information
that you can use to reason
about exactly what's going on
in your network.
And this is highly configurable.
So you can actually
expose as much data
or as little to suit
your specific use case
and purpose, right?
And for convenience sake,
what we've also done
is we have provided all of
this information as a JSON blob
that you can actually query
and perform post-analytics
and other use
cases to facilitate
whatever you need to achieve.
So once again, what are
these benefits, right?
So this kind of a
posture gives a record
of all your container's
action, regardless
of container lifetime.
So that's very, very important,
because as you can imagine,
in the traditional world
where let's say that there was
an exploit or a vulnerability,
you could actually
go in and perform forensics,
because that entity is actually
available there on your network.
It's not gone anywhere.
But containers are
highly ephemeral.
So if an exploit does happen,
I mean, that asset is gone.
It's no longer there.
But you need to have a record
of exactly what was going on
and the circumstances around
that particular exploit
or vulnerability to be able
to reason about what exactly
happened.
So you have now a record
of exactly what happened
and what is the use case there.
So you can now conduct
forensics armed
with full data and to actually
figure out what happens.
And now you can actually
improve your security posture.
So now you can also--
you also have the ability to
map your container activities
to malicious campaigns.
You can index and
integrate this.
Something that we have--
I'm going to get dinged
for this by Palo Alto,
but as a roadmap
item, we're actually
going to integrate this
with our threat intel cloud,
and we can actually
map these activities
to potential
malicious campaigns.
So that's an incredible
benefit, and it can also
may use that information to
enforce the right policies
on your deployments.
And last but not least,
it's highly useful
to perform security lifecycle
review and assessments
to say, hey, what's my posture?
What are the applications going?
What are the circumstances?
Are they secured?
What are the conditions that
are on these applications,
and can I actually
sanction these, right?
So those are a lot
of the benefits.
And that's the first
use case, which
is visibility into all aspects
of your container deployments.
The second use case and the
integration that we perform
is policy enforcement
for service meshes
on Kubernetes using Istio.
So I'm going to walk you
through a sequence of slides
to show how Palo Alto
has natively integrated
with Istio's capabilities
and the security framework
to give you this fine-grained
security posture.
So Palo Alto has a product
called Panorama, which
is our management platform.
So the Palo Alto-- the
Panorama has a plugin
that can interact with
Kubernetes clusters
to extract applications, labels,
microservices, et cetera.
So this is the
discovery piece where
we discover all the
services that are running
on your Kubernetes environment.
And we display that on
our Panorama interface.
Once that is done,
we can actually
deploy our security adapter
onto your Kubernetes/Istio
deployments to
actually retrieve.
The first thing that this
security adapter does
is it retrieves these policies
that a user now has actually
defined on Panorama.
So the workflow
there is that user
has a single, unified
security posture, where
they discover on the
Panorama platform
all the services
that are running.
And they can actually
script security policies
on our management
platform to define
what are the sanction
services and interactions
between the containers.
What the Palo Alto Network
security adaptor now does
is it retrieves these
policies from Panorama
and actually transforms them.
So I will spend a few
minutes in a later slide.
But we actually transform.
This is what I said.
So now you have
a unified posture
where you can define
security policies.
And we actually transform
them to Istio policies
and make it actionable
across your service mesh.
So for example, what does
this policy look like, right?
So you can say, hey, I need my
front end, my web application,
which is running in my
front end namespace.
It can access the application,
the application tier running
in the app tier namespace
on a specific port
and a specific application ID.
Similarly, you can
construct security policies
that allow access between
different namespaces
and different services, right?
So what we now do is then--
what happens is any time--
so before I get into
the how, so this
is like a typical
microservices deployment.
You have four
microservices here.
You have a web microservice, an
application microservice, DB,
and a pops up.
In this particular instance,
the web microservice
wants to talk to the
application microservice.
So the Envoy proxy, when that
happens, actually performs
a check call to the Palo
Alto Network security adapter
to say, hey, I have
the web service
in the front end
namespace that wants
to access the app servers
running in the app tier
namespace on this protocol with
this particular application ID.
So the security adapter now has
retrieved all these policies
and performed this
transformation.
And now it can say,
yep, I have an entry.
It matches.
I can actually allow this
particular connection
to go through.
So as you can see,
the web service
is not allowed to talk to
the application service.
Consequently, you know where
the next slide is going.
Let's say that your web
service gets exploited,
and there is a vulnerability.
And somebody has
been able to attack
that particular
application or container.
So suddenly, you
have your web service
trying to access
your DB tier, which
is arguably unsanctioned,
because only the application
service can access a DB tier.
This is where your
critical data resides.
So this is unsanctioned.
So similarly, however, Envoy
will actually make the call
to the Palo Alto
Networks adapter
to say, hey, I have this kind
of pattern access happening.
Is this sanctioned?
Clearly it's not,
because we don't
have any rule which
says that the web
service in the
front end namespace
can actually access the DB tier.
So consequently, this
access is denied.
Also want to point out that
all of this, even the policy
enforcement piece,
they are all logged
into both Stackdriver
and the Cortex Data Lake
for you to reason about.
So all of these are available
for post-processing.
So this slide here
gives you an idea
as to exactly how that
logging looks like.
So you can see that
you have at the top,
you can see that the Mixer sent
a check request to the Palo
Alto Network security adapter.
And we actually
performed a look up,
and you can see that there
were certain microservices
in different namespaces
accessing different destination
services.
And it goes through.
It performs a look up, and it
will actually also show you
whether that request
was allowed or denied.
Right?
So just to recap this, what
are the benefits, right?
You have consistent policy
definition, as you can see.
It's a unified, single
entity that security teams
need to define their policies
and then seamlessly apply
these kinds of Palo Alto
Network security policies,
for example, and
actually transform
them to make them actionable
across your container workloads
in different environments,
for either Kubernetes,
on premise, or even
your VM workloads.
So as I mentioned, it also
translates Palo Alto Network
security policies to
Kubernetes and Istio policies.
And then, as I
already mentioned,
this consistent logging
and feedback loop.
I just want to spend
maybe a minute talking
about how exactly we transform
these policies, as I'm
going to show you on
that demo so that you
have the right context there.
Palo Alto Networks is
trying to be as cloud native
and as container
native as possible.
And one of the artifacts
that we're able to leverage
is a concept called
dynamic address
groups, which is a very
versatile, scalable solution.
So what we do is for
all your namespaces,
we allow our users to define
Dynamic Address Groups,
add DAG tags, as I call it.
The tags represent all
the different services
that have been discovered from
your Kubernetes environments.
We add the source services.
Let's say that we know that
the web tier needs to talk
to the application tier.
So we will add all
the services which
form the source, which are
initiating connections,
to the source dynamic
address group.
Similarly, we add all
the destination services
to the destination
dynamic address group.
We add all of these
DAG tags, and this
is how we can translate the
Palo Alto Network security
policy into Istio policies.
And I'll show you exactly
how that comes into play.
So before we get into the
demo, another salient aspect
of this solution is the
fact that we can now
use a unified security
posture that is Panorama
and actually apply
security policies,
provide the visibility across
heterogeneous environments.
So for example, you can have
an open shift Kubernetes
cluster running on your
on-prem, and open shift
uses Istio for their policy
enforcement and traffic
management capabilities.
We can obviously run on GKE
or running on your GCP cloud
managed Kubernetes
provided by Google.
And last but not least,
we can also seamlessly run
this kind of a posture using
GKE running on your on premise
environments.
So all of these
entities, as you can see,
will fundamentally consist
of obviously Kubernetes.
And we will use--
the Panorama plugin
will actually
harvest the Kubernetes
labels, discover services,
provide that single pane for
discovery of all your services
across all of these
different environments
on a single, unified
console, for example.
We will then-- the
users, the operators,
will then define
security policies,
which can be highly automated.
Everything that you do at the
Palo Alto Networks devices
are all API driven.
And you can actually deploy
all your policies onto Panorama
and have them pushed to the
Next Generation Firewall Policy
engine.
That's the name of
our security adapter
that's available on
the Google Marketplace.
I'm going to talk about that
across all your different
environments.
And as you can see, you can
now have all that data visible
in your Cortex Data Lake.
And I also mentioned
I'm also going
to show you how we actually
aggregate all of the data
into Stackdriver as well.
So you can use a
unified platform
to now have a secure posture
across different heterogeneous
environments.
And that's an incredible
value that we see.
And why is this
important is the fact
that I've spoken to many
operators, many enterprises.
I mean, we are on this
continuous journey,
but it's not going
to happen overnight.
What we typically see is you
have your systems of engagement
that are potentially going to
be running on your Kubernetes
workloads and the
cloud, for example.
But they are going to be
accessing critical data that
is resident in your
databases, potentially
in your on prem environment.
So it's very
critical that you be
able to have a unified
posture to secure
all these different
environments,
because this is where Palo Alto
came from as well, by the way.
You can't have too many tools.
I mean, there's a
huge learning curve.
I mean, that's also not
a recipe for success.
So having a unified security
posture that you can actually
apply across all these different
environments is very important.
So I want to showcase the fact
that the Palo Alto Network
security solution is
it's brand spanking new.
There were a number
of announcements
that went out yesterday.
It's available on the
Google Marketplace,
and now you can actually
deploy the solution directly
onto your GKE clusters, running
on GCP, or on to GKE on prem.
And I'm going to
demo both of these.
So as you can see here,
from your Google console,
you can see two clusters.
The fact that one is indicated
as external on the top
means that that's
an on prem cluster.
So you can actually, from
the Google Marketplace,
you can deploy the solution
across both your on prem
and your cloud running on GCP--
GKE on GCP.
And then, Ivan, do you have
something to say about this?
IVAN BOJER: Yeah, I just want
to bring two salient points.
So number one, at
any point of time,
you don't have to deal
with the IP addresses.
All that magic
happens underneath.
So you really only deal with
the labels, Kubernetes labels,
which you're
familiar with, right?
Secondly, like as I've
showed you before,
you don't have to
worry about where
these containers are deployed.
As far as they're labeled
correctly, like a web service
or otherwise, we can set
up policies for those.
So your developers,
as far as they
label them or they have
a prescribed way of how
to label their containers, if
they're developing web service
or developing their persistent
storage or something like that,
you know, as a microservice,
that's all they have to do.
Security teams will just
apply policies automatically
on top of it.
So you don't have
to have any calls.
You don't have to open
a service now request.
You don't have to do anything.
Just deploy, label it,
and security folks.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN:
Yeah, and that's
a great point, because another
thing, another trend that Ivan
is pointing out is the fact that
developers need that agility.
I mean, we are always
hearing the fact
that security teams are
impeding that agility.
But what if we can now have a--
but security is a table stake.
What if we can now
show you how that it
can be a win-win situation,
if we can actually--
security can have a very
lightweight posture that really
doesn't impede the
agility that is
required from your developers
and the development team?
IVAN BOJER: And it
doesn't take away control
from the security teams.
I mean, that wouldn't
work for us anyway.
But they can work together.
I think that's very important.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: Yeah.
All right, so we've
spoken a lot so far.
Let's see.
Hopefully we can surface how
all of this works in action.
And I'm going to--
there's a cup out here.
I wasn't going to
challenge the demo gods,
but I think Google has
done a phenomenal job
with their Wi-Fi infrastructure.
But having said that, I'm
still going to run this video.
And if you could stick
with me, we will-- oops.
I'll walk you through
this video and show you
how exactly we pull
all of these concepts
that we've talked
about together.
I'm going to stand
here, because I'm going
to drive the video from here.
Oops.
So what we're starting off
here is the Google console.
And I want to show the fact
that we have multiple clusters
that we have deployed here.
And now we're actually
going to showcase
all the artifacts that have
been deployed on these clusters.
These are existing clusters,
and a highlight of the solution
is the fact that,
as you can see,
now let's say a
common use case is
our developers have gone
ahead and said, hey,
I need to use Kubernetes.
I need to run all
my applications.
This is the posture
that we need.
And then the security team
comes in and says, hey,
what's going on?
I need to know what's going on.
So these are existing clusters,
and we're going to showcase
how this lightweight
posture that security
can actually be layered
on without inhibiting
the developer agility.
So what you see over
here is the fact
that we have a very common,
popular microservice--
application, rather,
that's been defined.
It's got n number
of microservices.
For example, the carts
is the microservice.
Each one is a deployment.
It's also a service.
So you can see that there are
10 or 15 microservices that
have been deployed
onto this cluster.
So what we're going
to now show you
is how we onboard these
clusters into Panorama.
Panorama is the Palo Alto
Networks management platform,
and we use that to
onboard these clusters.
And what happens when these
clusters are onboarded
is that they actually
query the Kubernetes API
and perform a discovery.
So as you can see here, we have
discovered that there are--
at a high level, there are
four services, for example.
So you see the
front end service.
You see a shipping service,
an orders, and a payment.
So this goes back
to the fact that you
have, in this single
pane, you can discover
all the services
that are running
across n number of
clusters, existing
clusters across
different deployments
that you have on Kubernetes.
So we have a second
cluster, and we're also
going to show you how.
We're going to, at this
point, we don't have any,
apart from the Istio
ingress controller,
there are no services
that have been
discovered on that cluster.
So we're going to actually
deploy an application
onto the second cluster
and show you how
that these applications
are discovered and exposed
on the Panorama interface.
So as you can see here, this
is a very popular application.
I like to call it
the Hello World
application for Kubernetes,
but it's a very representative
application.
It's the book info
application, and it essentially
has four microservices.
One is the product page.
One is the details page,
ratings, and reviews.
What I didn't know,
and maybe I should just
preface this whole
demo with this,
is the fact that when I was
trying to refresh and apply
policy on this cluster, I
couldn't quite explain to Ivan.
He asked me the question,
hey, what's going on?
Why aren't you able to see all
the data on certain refreshes?
And I was like, eh, that's
how that application behaves.
And I really couldn't
have given a good answer.
But turns out with
all that visibility,
I was able to answer the fact
that there is a load balancer,
and it actually load balances
between different versions
of these microservices.
And that's also another
benefit of Kubernetes, right?
You can have different versions.
And you can actually
split traffic between all
these different versions.
And the fact that I wasn't
applying the right security
policy.
So it's essentially
the fact that we
are playing role reversal,
where he is a security team.
And I was like, hey, my
application doesn't work.
I don't know why
it doesn't work,
but you've got to provide
the right security policy.
IVAN BOJER: I think he
gave me actually great,
plausible answer,
which I bought in.
So--
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: [LAUGHS]
I said, I have no idea.
IVAN BOJER: You said something
which actually made sense.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: Did it?
OK, I'll take it.
But the point here is
that I was actually
able to go and
look into the logs
and see exactly
what was happening.
And I noticed that I didn't
have the right security policy.
But going through
with this demo,
you see all these
different services.
And now let's switch
context to Panorama,
where I can actually show
you that we have discovered
a lot of the micro-- on
all these microservices
that are running on
this particular cluster.
So I see that I don't
have all my services,
so you can actually
force a synchronization
between Panorama and
the Kubernetes cluster.
And once I do that, I see
that I have all my services
discovered.
So what this essentially
allows security teams to do
is they're coming back.
Their application
teams, the developers
are using Kubernetes
GKE, et cetera.
They've already deployed
their applications.
But I now, as a
security SecOps person,
need to know exactly what's
going on so that I can enforce
the right security policy.
So the next thing that
we're going to do here
is to show you how we
create those policies.
So now I know what services
are running, and I can say,
OK, I'm going to script
the security policies.
So I'm going to pause here.
So I just want to spend another
few seconds on exactly what's
going on here.
I talked about the
fact that we're
going to define
security policies,
because Palo Alto has a
lot of enterprise customers
that have a lot of
their development teams
moving to microservices,
Kubernetes, et cetera, right?
So they're used to
defining security policy
in a certain way.
But we also talked
about the fact
that that's not going to work.
We need to be able to reason
about namespaces, sources,
and apply security policy
with that kind of cadence.
So what we have done is we are
allowing our security operators
to define, as I mentioned, we're
going to define source groups,
where we will add all the
services that are going
to initiate the connections.
And we're going to add
destination address groups,
and we're going to
define the services that
are the recipients
for those connections.
And then we're also going to add
certain other attributes, which
will allow us to now
enforce this policy.
So I'm going to show you how we
are creating the source address
group, which is essentially
constituted with all
the services that are going
to initiate these connections.
And I'm going to add these
dynamic address group
tags, as I call it.
And what I've
actually done is I've
added all the different
services that I've discovered
in my cluster into my DAG tags.
And now I can add them, as these
are the source services that
are actually going to
initiate connections
to destination services.
And similarly, we do that
for the destination groups.
These are the tags.
And this now, we
actually use these tags
to define a security policy.
So as you can imagine, I have
a couple of different services.
And I'm going to define a
security policy for the book
info application.
And I also want to
showcase the fact
that this is highly scalable.
All you need to do is once
you define a security policy,
you just add tags to all the
different service pairs, if you
will, that you need to define.
So we're going to
actually leverage
the source dynamic address
group, which is called
book info source namespace.
And in the destination
side, we're
going to add all the
destination services.
So now you see we're
defining the security policy.
And on the right, you
can see here a service.
We can actually define
service objects.
What a service
object can represent
is what is the protocol that
is going to be leveraged.
For example, is it
going to be HTTP?
Is it going to be
HTTP2, GRPC, et cetera?
So you can define all aspects
of your service communications
and represented as
a security policy.
And I'm actually going
to show you that.
So you can see that we are
actually referencing the source
namespace, which is constituted
with all your source services.
Similarly for the
destination source,
we have also defined
what is the protocol.
The service, it's service HTTP.
And the action is to allow
this kind of traffic.
So once we have done
this, we can actually
commit this to Panorama, and
it's ready for consumption.
Whenever our security adapter
is deployed onto a Kubernetes
steel cluster, they
actually punch in
and check in with Panorama
to retrieve these policies.
So let's take a look at this.
Right now, the book info
application is up and running,
and it's accessible.
So let's now deploy the Palo
Alto Network security adapter
from the Google Marketplace.
So as you can see, I just wanted
to walk you through and show
how you can
configure and deploy.
You see all your
existing clusters.
You can pick and
choose which cluster
you want to deploy
this application into.
I picked the Panorama IP.
I pass it in as the
endpoint for where
I want to retrieve all
my security policies.
And then I deploy
the application.
The Google Marketplace
deploys the application
on that cluster, and it's up
and running at this point.
So what happens
now is I'm actually
going to switch contexts
and actually show you
what are the logs that when
this adapter is essentially
a container that is running on
your Kubernetes environment.
So it's actually
interacted and connected
with the Panorama device, and
it's retrieved the security
policies, as you can see.
And it's translated
those security policies
from the Palo Alto
Networks language
into policies that can be
applied across your cluster.
I'm going to quickly
pause here to show
that this is to represent how
you can actually now set up
your rules, as I told you.
So Istio needs to know, OK,
hey, I have an adapter here.
It's just sitting there.
What's it going to do?
But what you can see here
is now actually say, hey,
I'm going to define
an instance that
characterizes the data that I
want to send to this adapter.
So this is what we will leverage
from a logging perspective.
This is a very
subset of the data.
And similarly, we will
also define the rules,
according to which
Istio will send
the telemetry to our adapter.
And similar kind of a posture is
applied for your authorization
checks as well.
So this is what the YAML file
looks like to actually set up
all the plumbing for Mixer
to send a lot of the policy
checks and the log telemetry to
the Palo Alto Networks adapter.
And we are now going to
apply this YAML file.
So once we do
this, we see that--
which is what I told you,
which is I went through this.
You know, the rating
service is not available,
so I don't have the
right security posture.
I have a lot of
policies defined,
but something's missing.
So the next thing that
I did was I actually
went into the
Stackdriver interface
to say, hey, let's figure
out what's going on.
I have fine-grained data and
everything that happened.
So I know there are
authorization checks that
happened, and I know,
for example, there
was an access was allowed.
But there were also possibly
some accesses that were denied.
For example, I know
that reviews version 2,
there was the reviews
version 2 service was
talking to the rating service.
I had no clue, but
this is just the way
you can see which applications,
which microservices
need access and talking.
Similarly, I immediately
jump to my Panorama.
I updated my policy
to say, hey, OK,
I need to add a new service that
needs to initiate connections.
So the reviews version
2 service needs
to talk to the rating service.
I create a new tag for that.
I'm just giving you the
whole experience, right?
So forgive the pauses here.
But I now seamlessly, it gets
updated to the address book.
But you don't have to
update your security policy.
That's key here.
You just keep adding
services dynamically
to this address group, and it
can seamlessly get applied.
So we're only manipulating
the address group here.
We're adding the reviews
version 2 service we committed.
And then the new
policies get periodically
pulled by the adapter.
As you can see, we have the
reviews version 2 that can--
reviews version 2 can talk
to the rating service.
So now we have this
security policy.
Once we go here, now
your rating service
is available and accessible,
and you can see it.
So this just walks you
through the fact that now you
can actually go back
and corroborate.
Hey, OK, I actually had this
kind of an access happening.
I have all the logs
available to me.
But then what I
actually found here,
so what I'm actually saying
is, hey, we're not done yet.
There's another review
version 3 that wanted to talk.
So I'm going to speed
this up a little bit,
but we can similarly-- you
can see the cadence, right?
You can actually go and
add the new service,
and everything is
up and running.
But I just want to reiterate
the point that now you
have full visibility
into all the applications
and the workloads.
And then you know exactly what
were the authorization checks,
who was talking, whether access
was approved or denied, right?
And all of this data is
available on Stackdriver
and our Cortex Data Lake.
But what I want to actually
show you here is the deployment.
I'm going to-- sorry about this.
I'm going to showcase the
deployment of the Palo Alto
Network security adapter
onto the GKE on prem.
So directly from
your marketplace,
you can actually
deploy our adapter
onto your external
cluster, which
is actually sitting on your
on premise environments.
You go to the marketplace page.
You pick the adapter.
You configure it.
And you specify the
different deployment models,
and it actually seamlessly gets
deployed onto your cluster.
So once again, I
painted that picture
of heterogeneous environments.
And this is incredibly
valuable, because now you
have a unified security posture
with all your data aggregated
into either Stackdriver,
for example,
or the Palo Alto
Networks data lake.
And then you have
a unified framework
to actually deploy policy.
So you have discovery
and policy enforcement
from a single point.
So that kind of wraps up
actually in good time.
We have a few seconds
left, but, Ivan,
would you like to add anything?
IVAN BOJER: So just kind
of interesting point here
is that this is all
done in a live cluster,
without any
interruptions, right?
So just deploy the adapter,
and you can just start using it
as is.
So you may only have your
infrastructure deployed.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: Yeah.
IVAN BOJER: You want to
play around with this,
or you want to start using
it, you just deploy down,
and game on, right?
It's as easy as that.
VINAY VENKATARAGHAVAN: Yeah,
it's very easy to adopt.
And we have all the YAML
files on our GitHub pages.
But it's also been
incredibly more
easy to deploy now that
it's available on the Google
Marketplace.
You just point,
click, and it'll be
available and ready to deploy.
And please, we will be hanging
around for a few minutes.
Sorry we went right up
to our allocated time,
but we are happy to
answer any questions.
And thank you so much.
IVAN BOJER: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]